>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE WANT TO BEGIN THIS EVENING
WITH THE QUIZ APPEARED QUICK.
WHAT DOES THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S
STAND FOR?
THAT USED TO BE AN EASY QUESTION
TO ANSWER 400 YEARS, THE ANSWER
WAS HIGHER WAGES AND BETTER
BENEFITS.
I WAS BACK ON THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WAS RUN BY
PEOPLE WHO WORKED FOR A LIVING.
THEY CARED ABOUT HOW MUCH VOTERS
GOT PAID AT THE END OF THE WEEK.
BUT THAT'S NOT A SUBJECT THAT
INTERESTS THE DECADENT RICH VERY
MUCH FOR THE PRIVATE EQUITY
BILLIONAIRES WHO FUND TO GET
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY COULD
CARE LESS WHAT OTHER PEOPLE'S
WAGES WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT MOST
OTHER THAN MAKING THEMSELVES
EVEN RICHER IS FEELING VIRTUOUS.
FEELING LIKE A DEEPLY GOOD
PEOPLE.
MUCH BETTER THAN YOU ARE.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY ARE SO
COMMITTED TO SOMETHING CALLED
DIVERSITY.
A CONCEPT THAT NOBODY'S WILLING
TO EXPLAIN BUT THAT NONETHELESS
WE MUST CELEBRATE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY AND
PERPETUALLY.
LISTEN TO NANCY PELOSI EXPLAIN.
>> BIODIVERSITY, THAT IS OUR
STRENGTH.
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH.
OUR DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH.
I ALWAYS SAY THAT DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH.
AND I STATED TO THE CAUCUS, OUR
DIVERSITY IS OUR RESTRAINT.
THE FACT IS, OUR DIVERSITY IS
OUR STRENGTH.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
GOT IT?
DIVERSITY IS OUR STRENGTH.
THEY MADE UP HER CRYSTAL CLEAR.
WHAT IS STILL UNCLEAR IS WHAT
EXACTLY DIVERSITY IS PAIRED WHAT
IS IT?
WELL, FOR ONE THING, DIVERSITY
IS THE REASON THAT ALLISON CHILD
BUT WAS FORCED TO RESIGN HER DOG
JOB IN HER'S GRACE PERIOD UNTIL
24 HOURS AGO, SHE WAS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN AND YESTERDAY SHE QUIT
IN TEARS.
SHE ASKED HER COLLEAGUES TO
FORGIVE HER AS SHE PACKED HER
THINGS.
WHAT DID SHE DO WRONG?
WELL, NOTHING, ACTUALLY.
SHE DIDN'T HURT ANYONE.
INSANE THING AWFUL TO HER SHE
DIDN'T MISMANAGE THE OFFICE
PAIRED NOBODY CLAIMS DID.
JAZZ WAS ONLY FADED BUT WAS
HAVING THE WRONG SKIN COLOR.
ON SUNDAY, TWO CONGRESSIONAL
DEMOCRATS DEMANDED THAT SHE BE
FIRED FROM HER JOB AND REPLACED
BY A PERSON OF THE DIFFERENT
HUE.
ON A MORE COMPETENT PERSON COME
DIDN'T MENTION THAT.
I WAS SO WOULD RELEVANT.
BUT JUST A DIFFERENT COLORED
PERSON.
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERED TO
THEM.
SO THEY FORCED A PERSON OUT OF
HER JOB FOR HAVING THE WRONG
JEANS.
APPARENTLY NONE OF THIS SET OFF
ANY ALARM BELLS OVER A
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HQ.
APPARENTLY NOBODY COULD THINK OF
ANY OTHER TIME IN HISTORY WHERE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAD
HAPPENED.
IT DIDN'T SEEM OMINOUS TO THEM
WERE CREEPY OR RACIST.
IT JUST SEEMS LIKE DIVERSITY,
WHICH WE MUST CELEBRATE BECAUSE
IT IS OUR STRENGTH.
THAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS GONE
INSANE.
YOU MAY THINK YOU ALREADY KNEW
THAT BUT EVEN IF YOU THINK YOU
KNEW IT, IT'S HARD TO APPRECIATE
JUST HOW REAL IT IS.
JUST HOW CRAZY THE PARTY HAS
BEGUN.
THE PARTY OF ORDINARY AMERICANS
HAS BECOME A POISONOUS IDENTITY
COLT OBSESSED WITH QUESTIONS OF
RACIAL PURITY.
IT'S TERRIFYING, BUT IT'S
ENTIRELY REAL.
HOW REAL IS IT?
WELL, I'LL SHARPTON IS NOW A
HERO ON THE LEFT.
THAT KIND OF SUMS IT UP.
FOR 40 YEARS, SHARP AND CHASTE
HUSTLE AFTER ANOTHER, RAISED
HIM, AT THE INFORMANT, SHAKEDOWN
ARTISTS, IF YOU TOLD AL SHARP IN
1995 THAT SOMEDAY HE WOULD BE
THE MORAL CONSCIENCE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, HE WOULD HE
WOULD'VE LAUGHED IN HER FACE.
ANNETTE, COME HERE WE ARE AND
HERE HE IS.
>> THIS IS A RACE BAITING AT ITS
BEST.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP PLAYING THE
RACE CARD AND IT IS A SHAME AND
IT IS A SHAM.
HE IS PLAYING THE RACE BAITING
CROWD.
HE IS PLAYING A RACE DIVISIVE
CARD.
HE SHOULD NOT CONTINUE TO TRY
AND SELL THIS RACIST BEHAVIOR TO
TRY AND MAKE THE COUNTRY MORE
DIVIDED FOR HIS OWN POLITICAL
GAIN.
>> Tucker: THERE YOU HAVE
APPEARED AL SHARPTON, THE MEN
WHO ONCE ATTACKED AND CRACKERS
AS PARASITES, BEMOANING OUR
DIVIDED NATION.
HILARIOUS.
THE LEADING DEMOCRATS DON'T
APPEAR TO GET THE JOKE.
JUST TODAY, POOR OLD JOE BIDEN
TWEETED THIS QUOTE.
"THE REVEREND AL IS A CHAMPION
IN THE FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS."
SURE.
IF THE FIGHT FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IS
A EUPHEMISM FOR BUYING MORE
$10,000 SUITS IN WHICH CASE, AL
SHARPTON IS A LEGITIMATE HERO IN
THAT FIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE SEEM TO
THINK HE REALLY IS.
WATCH THEM KISS HIS RING ADDED
AN EVENT THIS SPRING.
>> THAT HAD IT, WHO IS ARE TRULY
RIGHT NOW THE STEWARD OF THE
ONGOING MOVEMENT FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS JUSTICE IN OUR COUNTRY,
AND THAT'S THE REVEREND I'LL
SHARPTON.
>> BEING ON THE FOREFRONT IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST RACISM AND FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE, AL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL THAT YOU ARE DOING.
>> I KNOW THAT WHEREVER SHARPTON
IS, AND THIS IS NOT THE PLACE
FOR TALK.
THIS IS THE PLACE FOR ACTION.
>> PEOPLE LIKE REVEREND
SHARPTON, WHO HAVE NEVER STOPPED
FIGHTING FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE.
>> REV, I CANNOT THANK YOU
ENOUGH FOR YOUR YEARS OF
FRIENDSHIP, YOUR YEARS OF
LEADERSHIP.
>> I WANT TO SAY TO REVEREND AL
SHARPTON, THANK YOU.
FOR LEADING.
THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING OUT.
THANK YOU FOR SHOWING US AWAY.
>> Tucker: THERE YOU HAVE IT.
THE MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY SO
DISTORTED BY RACE GUILT THAT AL
SHARPTON SEEMS LIKE A MORAL
LEADER.
THIS IS NUTS.
IT'S ALSO A RECIPE FOR AN
ELECTORAL WIPEOUT.
THERE IS A LOT ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THEIR
ECONOMIC PLATFORM THAT ORDINARY
VOTERS MIGHT LIKE BUT THIS KIND
OF GARBAGE?
IT'S A DEAL KILLER.
NOT JUST FOR A CONSERVATIVE
WHITE VOTERS, NO NORMAL PERSON
OF ANY ACCOUNT WILL VOTE STUFF
LIKE THIS.
FORMER CHICAGO MAYOR DOES
UNDERSTAND THAT.
THIS BECOME A MANUAL PUBLISHED A
MEMO AIMED AT THE PARTY'S
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
HE BEGGED THEM TO RETURN TO
REALITY IMMEDIATELY.
HERE'S PART OF IT.
QUOTES "BEFORE OUR PARTY
PROMISES THE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE TO UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS, LET'S HELP THEM MORE
THAN 30 MILLION AMERICANS WHO
ARE A SINGLE ILLNESS AWAY FROM
FINANCIAL RUIN BEFORE WE START
WORRYING ABOUT WHETHER THE
BOSTON MARATHON BOMBER CAN VOTE,
LET'S STOP THINGS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO CURTAIL
VOTING RIGHTS OF CITIZENS.
AND BEFORE WE PROMISED A
GUARANTEED MINIMUM INCOME TO
HEALTHY ADULTS WHO PREFER TO
STAY HOME AND PLAY VIDEO GAMES,
LET'S INCREASE THE MINIMUM WAGE
END OF THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT TO THE BENEFIT OF THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO STILL
WORK HARD AND LIVE NEAR POVERTY.
"THERE WERE MANY TIMES, FOR
EXAMPLE, AMERICAN TAXPAYERS HAVE
SPENT THE LAST 20 YEARS BOTH IN
BLOOD AND TREASURE BUILDING
ROADS, SCHOOLS, AND HOSPITALS IN
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN PEERED ALLT
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN PEERED ALLE
WHILE, AND AMERICAN WAGES
CONTINUE TO STAGNATE.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF BEING
TREATED AS CHUMS.
IT'S TIME TO ADJUST AND INVEST
IN AMERICA AGAIN.
>> THE MOMENT MEMO WAS FULL OF
GOOD ADVICE.
IT WAS INVITED BY EVERYTHING
OBVIOUSLY BUT A LEAST HE FOCUSES
ON THE RIGHT THINGS BUT MOST
AMERICANS ACTUALLY AREN'T
OBSESSED WITH RACE.
THEY DON'T WANT TO MEMORIZE 60
NEW GENDERS.
THERE AREN'T 60 NEW GENDERS.
THERE ARE TWO GENDERS AND
EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
THEY DON'T THINK IT'S THEIR DUTY
TO GIVE AMERICAN SUFFICIENT
CITIZENSHIP TO EVERYONE ON THE
PLANET ALONG WITH HEALTH CARE.
COME ON.
INSTEAD THEY HAVE A MORE BASIC
HOPE.
THEY WANT TO FEEL THAT THE
COUNTRY THEY WERE BORN AND IT IS
THEIR HOME.
THEY WANT LEADERSHIP TO PUT
THEIR INTEREST FIRST.
THE LEADERS WHO ACTUALLY CARE
ABOUT THEIR WELL-BEING.
AND YET, WEIRDLY, FOR DECADES,
WASHINGTON HAS REFUSED TO SUPPLY
LEADERS LIKE THAT.
THAT'S WHY DONALD TRUMP ONE AND
2016.
THAT'S WHY HE VERY EASILY COULD